welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousin sitting in for david
pakman and hey if you like what you've
heard from me these last two days you
can follow me on my two youtube channels
youtube.com slash the ring of fire i'm
also
youtube.com fair and balanced and
twitter facebook instagram and if you're
so inclined tick tock i'm at fahren
balanced
we've still got a lot to cover and not a
whole lot of show left folks so let's
get right back into it we've got a new
poll this week that i think
tells us more than what the pollsters
thought it was telling us
and it is this for the first time this
year the number one issue on the minds
of american voters as we head into the
midterms is not
the economy it's not inflation it's not
anything
having to do with their personal
finances
the number one issue
or i should say the most popular issue
for american voters because it's only at
14 but everything is lower than that or
sorry 21 but everything else is lower
than that
is
threats
to democracy
21
a plurality of voters
say the number one issue they have on
their minds right now heading into the
midterms
are the growing
threats
to democracy
it's not surprising is it
because what i think this really tells
us
is
the january 6 hearings have worked
that's why threats to democracy
is at the forefront of everybody's
brains right now
because we are watching the threats to
democracy or at least we were over the
summer unfold on tv those hearings by
the way are going to resume once again
in september which is wonderful we need
them to
you know we kind of had like the the
season finale in the summer now we're
ready for season two
because they left us a lot of
cliffhangers that we need resolved
before the midterms and if republicans
take back over we kind of have to get on
that quick because they're going to kill
the committee and several of the members
will no longer be in congress liz cheney
and adam kinzinger obviously
but 21
isn't a huge percentage right because
you still have other ones um
16
chose cost of living
as the you know second most important 14
said jobs in the economy
57 percent by the way say the
investigation into former president
donald trump should continue so
when we see these numbers that say 21
percent say the threats to democracy are
number one please understand a majority
of people are directly referring to
donald frickin trump
it's not like we're dealing with trump
supporters who think oh the threat to
democracy of the fbi barging in on the
former president making him cry
nope
these are people who look at donald
trump
they look at january 6 they look at all
the investigations and you know criminal
allegations out there and they say you
know what
that's that that's very concerning to me
and
furthermore
knowing now that this has emerged as the
biggest issue for american voters
it also helps explain why we've seen the
shifts in these polls in just the last
couple weeks
right
ever since biden was sworn in as
president all the polls already showed
us republicans are going to sweep the
2022 midterms
and it's not just the polls that were
telling us that history tells us that
typically
when a new president takes power if the
party also controls congress they will
lose control of congress in the first
midterms following their you know first
year in office
that's historically what happens it's
only not happened a handful of times so
historically it was supposed to happen
the polls were showing it was totally
going to happen and now the polls are
showing that oops generic democrat beats
generic republican
so sometimes we have to take all of this
polling data
you know like for example this stuff
says well a majority of voters say the
threat to democracy is number one now
these polls show democrats are now
possibly going to win the midterms
but but you have to finish the work you
have to put the polls together
you know my degree is in political
science and that is literally
one of the things that they teach you in
the political polling classes is how to
take the data from all the different
polls
and put it all together
to extrapolate what it actually means
and unfortunately i see too few
individuals out there doing that
you can't just report on hey here's a
new poll blah blah see you later no you
have to tie it in and make it relevant
to everything
and that's what too few groups are not
doing because that's not mentioned in
this story
it should be but it's not
so
brush up on your poli sci folks because
that's how you read polls you don't read
them individually you read them as a
part of something bigger